Ohh, endlich Feierabend ey! Uuh!
Hmm, irgendwie hab ich voll Lust auf was Süßes.
Oh, ich muss ja eigentlich Diät machen..
Ach, mir doch egal! Ich nehm mir jetzt einfach was!
Oh lecker, Snickers! Oaah!
Hallo? Alles leer?!
Eyy, ist das euer Ernst?
Ja, ein Toffifee!...Ein Toffifee?
Dat reicht mir nicht!
Und deshalb mach ich mir jetzt ein Toffifee in XXL-Größe!
Und das zu machen, ist garnicht so schwer. Ich zeig euch jetzt Schritt für Schritt die Zubereitung.
Für das Karamell benötigen wir 200g Creme fraiche,
150g weißen Zucker und 150g braunen Zucker.
Keine Angst vorm Karamell machen!
Meine Variante ist super einfach.
Dafür gebe ich alle drei Zutaten in einen Topf und verrühre das kurz miteinander.
Dann geh ich rüber zum Herd und erhitze das Ganze,
gebe den Deckel drauf und lasse es aufkochen.
Nach dem Aufkochen schalte ich das Ganze auf mittlere Stufe,
und lasse es fünf Minuten lang weiterköcheln.
Wichtig ist, dass dabei nicht umgerührt wird.
Mithilfe meines Thermometers schaue ich dann nach, wie viel Grad das Ganze erreicht hat,
eine Temperatur von 135° sind perfekt, denn dann lösen sich die Zuckerkristalle auf.
Hier bitte vorsichtig sein, denn es herrscht Verbrennungsgefahr.
Und deshalb gebe ich das Karamell 5 Minuten lang an die Seite und
mach mit dem Haselnusskern weiter.
Dafür benötigen wir 40g gehackte Haselnüsse und 40g Zucker.
Den Zucker lasse ich bei mittlerer Hitze in meinem Topf schmelzen und gebe
anschließend die Haselnusskerne hinzu.
Die Haselnuss-Zucker Masse muss dann immer wieder verrührt werden
und nach ca. 1-2 Minuten sind wir auch schon fertig.
Die Masse ist auch wieder sehr, sehr heiß, also zieht euch am besten Handschuhe an,
lasst das Ganze zur Not ein paar Minuten stehen
und dann könnt ihr sie zu einer Kugel formen.
Den Haselnusskern legen wir bis zur Weiterverarbeitung an die Seite.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr jetzt für die Weiterverarbeitung eine geeignete Form verwendet.
Ich habe hier eine Silikonform, die lässt sich super dehnen.
Auch von hinten habe ich später keine Probleme, das Toffifee rauszubekommen.
Und da gebe ich jetzt mein Karamell hinein.
Nun wird das Karamell in der Form gedreht, hin und her
bis es allmählich auskühlt und abhärtet.
Das kann bis zu 10 Minuten dauern.
Zur Not auch noch ein bisschen mit den Fingern nachhelfen.
Und dann kann auch schon die Nougatcreme zubereitet werden.
Dafür benötigen wir 650g Nutella, 350g Vollmilchkuvertüre
und 350g Zartbitterkuvertüre.
Die Creme geht jetzt super schnell und einfach, dafür werden alle 3 Zutaten in eine
Schüssel gegeben und miteinander verrührt.
Für die Zusammenstellung des Toffifees ist wichtig, dass das Karamell komplett ausgehärtet ist.
In die Mitte lege ich dann den Haselnusskern und darüber die Nuss-Nougat Creme.
Die Creme wird dann noch einmal schön glattgestrichen mit einer Winkelpalette
und anschließend wird das Ganze nochmal durchgekühlt.
Nach 2h im Kühlschrank gebe ich dann Zartbitter Kuvertüre oben drauf,
das mache ich mithilfe meiner Lochtülle in kreisenden Bewegungen.
und gebe das nochmal zum Kühlen in den Kühlschrank.
Mit meiner Winkelpalette streiche ich das dann nochmal schön glatt
Und schon ist euer XXL Toffifee fertig!
Ihr müsst es nur noch aus der Silikonform befreien, das geht aber auch super easy,
einfach von unten herausdrücken.
Natürlich darf auch das große Wiegen nicht fehlen!
Hier haben wir ein zuckersüßes kleines Toffifee
mit 8 leichten Gramm.
Und dann kommt unser XXL Toffifee mit 2175g.
Ich denke, das reicht mir!
So, ich brauch jetzt was süßes.
Ein Toffifee noch!
Ich ess den letzten Toffifee!
Mach doch, mir doch egal!